When Drew first interviewed me for her show,
she asked who I was most starstruck by,
and I told the story about Paul McCartney,
and, you know, it got me thinking about
meeting your idols.
There's kind of three ways it can go.
One, you meet your favorite celebrity
and they're a monster and you go,
"Oh, I shouldn't have met my idol."
Two, you meet your idol
and they're exactly what you want them to be.
And actually you go, "This is amazing,"
which is like Paul McCartney.
And then third option is meet a celebrity.
and that celebrity is Drew Barrymore,
and she is so stunning
and warm and endearing
and interested in you that you walk away thinking,
"Wow, like, wait, Drew Barrymore isn't just a celebrity,
I think she's my best friend."
That's how I felt when I met Drew for the first time.
I was on Saturday Night Live, Drew was hosting.
She was so creative
and had a thousand ideas and was so giving
and I remembered she was going over cue cards
and someone's trying to wig,
and as it was happening, some other person came over
and said, "Drew, I just wanted to show you,
I have a tattoo of you on my leg."
And she was like, "That is so, oh, that's beautiful."
But this happened in like 10 seconds of,
can you imagine someone's life,
that happens to you in 10,
and totally multitask, cool as a cucumber,
just like, "Yeah, oh yeah."
And just honestly, just, I'll never forget it.
And luckily I got to be friends with Drew
from that moment on until now.
I'm very, very lucky.
She's one in a zillion.
No matter who you are,
she makes you feel like the most important person
in the room,
but don't just take my word for it.
Here's some other folks who were just as starstruck by Drew.
(upbeat music)
One time I was starstruck was definitely on the set
of a movie that I did called "The Stand In"
where I had to play the opposite Drew Barrymore!
Drew Barrymore, that's the time that I was starstruck.
I've asked for a photo of two celebrities in my entire life.
One was Drew Barrymore
and I won't say who the other one was
because that person did not say yes.
But yes, Drew Barrymore, I was starstruck when I met her.
A moment I was starstruck was the morning
that I had to talk to Drew Barrymore on her show.
The first one is a time you've been starstruck.
Just happened. (laughs)
She gets so excited, I'm like, "Okay Erin, don't overreact."
Really, Drew Barrymore? Really?
Just happened.
Oh gosh. Right now
Oh my God, it's hard to top this one.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah, right now. For sure.
Meeting Drew on SNL was I, you know,
I was completely starstruck
and very shy to the point where I just,
I couldn't believe she was talking to me.
It was a moment where, very early in my career, really,
before my career got started,
for Drew to talk to me and be so nice to me in the hallway.
Yeah. I'll never forget that.
One of the moments where I was the most starstruck,
to be honest with you, was right when "Queer Eye"
was premiering, season one, this was in 2017.
We went to our first Netflix party,
and this is the God honest truth,
Drew Barrymore walked in and she was the first celebrity
ever to talk to myself and the cast.
We have all talked about this moment where Drew was
just so sweet, so kind.
I still have a group photo of all of us.
She was our very first celebrity to ever say, "Good luck.
You're gonna make it, you're doing good in the world."
And when you have people who you look up to
and honor saying that you're gonna do good,
you just hold tight to that.
And so I still thank Drew for that moment
and look at us!
Full circle, here we are.
(upbeat music)